when it comes to Dark Souls 2 on the PC
you've probably got an important
question on your mind has developer from
software learned it's lessons to prepare
to die edition of the original Dark
Souls is notorious for being a
lackluster port of an amazing experience
but it was limited to a 1024 by 768
resolution
so changing the in-game resolution
options didn't actually affect the
rendering resolution the resulting
visuals were blurry and did too little
to show off the game's impressive art
design
additionally the port was capped at 30
frames a second the keyboard mouse
support was abysmal and the mouse cursor
remained on the screen trailing around
when you used mouse look PC gamers
rightfully expected better and
rightfully they expect that Dark Souls 2
will not suffer from the same kinds of
problems and so I bring you some good
news Dark Souls 2 is straight away a
better port than the original Dark Souls
was when you set the resolution to 1920
by 1080 what you see is actually 1920 by
1080 the game runs at a brisk 60 frames
per second even on a modest PC and while
you're stuck looking at Xbox 360
controller button prompts you still can
play the game comfortably with mouse and
keyboard and so in this respect the PC
version looks better than the console
versions the higher resolution and
sharper textures give places like majula
and hidest Tower of flame greater visual
definition details on armor are easier
to admire and subtle touches like the
intricate carvings on statues and stone
pathways stand out all the more this is
all well and good and in the world of PC
gaming expected on the other hand if you
are hoping for the PC version to
showcase the impressive lighting we saw
in pre-release video you'll be sad to
learn the lighting remains flat on the
PC just as it was on consoles another
interesting question to ask is how the
sequel compares to Dark Souls when
you've applied popular community-created
graphical enhancement
to the original and so I played the
original Dark Souls with two mods apply
dsfix by Durante on Nexus mods and two
ology 86 is High Definition texture pack
also from Nexus Dark Souls 2 looks more
impressive than the modded original in
certain respects featuring typography
that looks more organic and less severe
than in Dark Souls the draw distance 2
offers more clarity in Dark Souls 2 than
in the original on the other hand two
ology 86's excellent textures make the
crumbling stone work seen an undead
parish look more weathered and chipped
then do similar textures in Dark Souls
2's lost Bastille additionally in the
modded Dark Souls the dark is darker and
illumination without obvious sources is
less common it goes without saying of
course that Dark Souls 2 on the PC feels
just as it did on consoles and in that
respect it seems likely that the game
will be enchanting a new community of
players come April 25th on that day I
look forward to joining each of you in a
show of jolly cooperation
you